qu'est ce qui lui arrive à kazim la
bizarre
dis moi qui ai mis un casque assaillent
casimir qu'est ce qui t'arrive tu es
malade
non j'ai oublié quelque chose tu oublié
quelque chose moi un objet non j'ai
oublié ce que je suis venu faire ici
aujourd'hui
as tu es venu dire bonjour à nos amis tu
crois oui bonjour vous allez bien je
voulais un parent non rien non c'est pas
ça c'est pas ça et bien du est peut être
venue pour nous chanter ta chanson a
peut-être tu croirais on va voir mais
alors attention deux fois non c'est pas
ça la musique n'a pas démarré
c'est pas ça non plus alors moi je pense
je vois pas
c'est bête parce qu'avec un seul mon jeu
je me souviendrai de ce que je suis venu
faire un seul mot ce serait pas de nous
divulguer par hasard non c'est pas ça et
bien glace aux anchois
non non j'ai pas leur écoute des
toboggans octobre quand tu dis n'importe
quoi pourquoi pas à nénuphars aux
hippopotames
si c'est pour faire semblant de médéa
avec des bêtises pareilles c'est pas la
peine un autre vieux très bien plus que
d'une pente comme ça casimir du
débrouille tout seul
allez au revoir julie la ville a tout de
suite oui j'ai dit au revoir julie c'est
tout cas merci françois merci tu en as
me farmine à caen soirs mais mais mais
qui suis tourné pour surfacturer fou tu
perds la tête j'ai rien d'extraordinaire
mais si tu as dit au revoir julie est
alors alors julie c'est ça c'est le mot
que j'avais oublié attend de ce n'est
vraiment rien de mystérieux casimir et
que dois tu faire avec julie ah ça c'est
un choc hype à ce qu'il aura bientôt une
grande surprise à redon et bien
j'attends la surprise et je vous laisse
tous les deux au revoir au revoir
julie oui ou jeudi dans sa bonne mine ce
matin tu trouves oui tu as l'air en
plein far away
tu sais c'est à cause de ma gymnastique
matinale
je suis très sportif oui d'ailleurs
c'est pour ça que je suis si mince mais
tu veux pour être danseur étoile je
crois qu'il faut qu'il soit encore un
peu plus mince et un peu plus musclée
c'est un peu mou tout ça mais moi je
suis au travail
je suis venu pour ça julie c'est lors de
ma leçon mais c'est vrai javou alors
ont-ils dit
voilà
attention première position des jambes
bien droite un genou bien tiré un
terrier 1 2 3 5 6 du clip bien sûr car
ou trois autres tu t'es tire bien 1 2 3
4 et flector alors la seconde car en
fait on voit parfait bien ouvert la même
chose
1 2 3 les bras très large l'aller 2-3
core 2 3 4 contre l'eire tu te tires au
maximum et devient les chiens en arrière
maintenant la 4e dan ariely si tu fais
bien ton poids du corps au milieu vieux
genoux bien tordu oui bien fléchi
3 4 voilà bah tu crois que tu es passé
chauffer comme ça moi savoir si jacques
plein droit on va commencer dans moins
d'accord au mondial marat temps à temps
mais là par là attends je rends mon
chapeau way à l'elac voilà bon
voilà c'est ma cousine à des live qui va
être jalouse
c'était son rêve de jeune fille
[Musique]
on
huawei
[Musique]
bon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui
bon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]